>> So, the mean does have a simple equation. And if you remember, it's the sum
of x divided by n. The mean will also always change if any data value changes.
Median will sometimes change, and mode will also sometimes change. The mean is
not affected by change bin size, it will always be the same, no matter how we
visualize the data with a histogram, and the same with the median. But you've
seen that the mode does change, it becomes a new interval if we change the bin
size. You saw in the case of the Michael Jordan example that the mean is
affected by outliers, but the median not as much, so not severely affected, same
with the mode. And finally, it is kind of hard to find the mean and median on
the histogram. But you always know which one the mode is, because it's the
highest frequency.